let me go next to our caller from the
3-1 to area code who's calling today
from three one two
hi David this is Priscilla I'm from
Chicago hey Priscilla what's going on I
am just wondering what's your take on
you know there's a lot of job item
sexual assault allegations and I am NOT
a trump supporter I would never vote for
him in my life but I honestly also don't
feel comfortable voting for someone
who's had so many sexual assault
allegations and I honestly feel like at
least some of them are credible and yeah
you I don't know how I feel about that
so I'm aware we talked earlier about the
Tara Reid allegations which which other
allegations are you referring to I'm not
sure the names agree but it's mostly
just you know am i comfortable voting
for someone who even has these
allegations against them at all because
it's it's kind of it would be
hypocritical of me to be like oh I don't
want to vote for a Donald Trump because
he's a racist or whatever but then go
and vote for someone like Joe Biden
booth has really done the same thing to
other people but so is there any
allegation other than the Tara Reid one
that you're aware of um
I am not specifically aware of any other
names but I've heard that there are
multiple allegations so maybe I'm just
not informed enough well there's
definitely a blending together of like
Biden hugged a senator's daughter and it
was weird and the Tara Reid thing so
here's here's my view and I've sort of
stated it already but here's how I think
it applies to voting um every woman's
allegations should be taken seriously
and investigated what Tara Reid is
alleging is serious and it deserves
investigation she deserves to be heard
this is my view regardless of the
political party of accuser accused
whatever period and full stop where I
would next go to is great you don't like
you don't want to vote for anyone who's
been accused of anything like that
perfect the next question is what else
do you care
about right in the sense that so Trump's
been accused by sixteen seventeen twenty
to forty six women according to one book
we know that he's paid off some women
his own wife under threat of perjury in
a deposition accused him of raping her
etc and then we do have the Tara Reid
allegation with Biden where are you on
climate where are you on taxation where
are you on coronavirus response where
are you on education where are you on
diplomacy is there any difference there
in terms of your view on Trump vs. Biden
oh absolutely I mean I just think Biden
is stronger on all those issues banned
Trump and he's it goes back to what you
always say you know he it's kind of
picking who I would rather have you know
rightly not my idea I voted for Bernie
in the primary and I wish I could vote
for him again in the general however I
am still considering voting for Biden
just because I really don't want Trump
back in right so another Priscilla if I
say to you who do you prefer Trump or
Biden is there a clear answer in your
mind by them so so then is there any
question about what you should do in
November there is still just because I
don't know like he's just not the person
I want and it goes back to you know do I
really want you know it's so hard
because I am pulled in both directions
like yes I don't want Donald Trump I
also don't want to just get Biden my
vote just because you know and what the
Democrats are expected it sounded like
you were saying it's not just because in
other words you said you preferred Biden
over Trump I listed six or seven policy
issues and you said Biden's better right
you said that about a minute ago yeah so
it's not really just because it sounds
like you've analyzed their positions on
policy and you've decided which one's
better yeah I have I just I don't know I
feel kind of I still feel some
hesitation and I'm not sure hmm I still
feel like I will vote for him but I know
I don't know and I know a lot of people
I don't I saying
both that they're just kind of feeling
my go noise like we're in a rock and a
hard place we're forced to vote for
someone who were not completely behind
which I get that's kind of always the
case at different degrees I mean no I
I'm not I've never voted for anyone I'm
completely behind it's always who are
you more behind and it sounds like
you're pretty damn clear about that yeah
I am I am I've just been such a Bernie
supporter since high school and now this
is going to be my first time voting and
yeah it's not the way I plan but thank
you for your time
Priscilla I can tell from talking to you
that you're gonna do the right thing in
November thank you your honor all right
take care have a good all right I
apologize for everybody I was not able
to get to we are out of time today but
we will take calls again really
appreciate you joining me quick break
more after this